I could just show you what the answer is
which is sorry the question it helps if
you know the question is the question is
that and the answer is 13 okay but the
question is why okay and it illustrates
a problem-solving process that you
really need to master in order to
because you'll get more of these and you
won't have me sitting in the example bit
with you working examples through the
help you understand so if you've got
this question
that's great quietly move on if you did
not then you can pay attention okay now
this is a great question because they
give you an astonishingly small amount
of data to work with
okay which actually is really good for
you that limits the number of choices
you've got if you so choose
and are able if you go ahead and do the
extension to at the end of this year in
next year you'll learn all of these
different kinds of integration now even
if you don't know what integration is
the whole point is there's a lot of
different for every different kind of
function that there is there's a
different way to integrate it and when
you're going to extension to you learn
like twice as many ways to interact and
so you can integrate try so many things
so you have all of these traces sort of
in your head you're like which way do I
approach this and this question is
obviously opposite you always have no
choices as to which way you can go which
actually does you a favor you have this
thing and then you have a sum of cubes
right so if you have a sum of cubes
what's your immediate first isn't it you
should you should write out the identity
for the sum of cubes right which
hopefully if you remember from last week
looks like this okay right now you look
at this and you think okay this is my
expansion but I know what are the parts
of this and how to like actually
evaluate them right I know what XQ plus
y cubed is I also know what X plus y is
you see that it's just multiplied
through I don't even need to write it I
just end up with this okay now this is
good because it has in it contains
within it what I'm after but then it has
this sum
how's this little spanner in the works
there so then the question becomes well
how do I eliminate that what do I do
in order to get that out of the way and
solve now again like I said before
they're doing you an enormous favor by
providing you with a very small amount
of information okay because if this is
all you've got to go off then you know
that in order to solve this problem what
you need must be tucked in here
somewhere the question is well now being
that there's an X Y and that's the
problem
do you think the X cubed plus y cubed is
going to help you it's not is it because
to go for an X cube 2 plus y cubed 2 X Y
is extraordinarily difficult you'd have
to tie yourself an algebraic knots to
get that out of them whereas when you
look at this line actually is quite easy
to get an X Y out of there what should
we do to it we should square so if I
take that first line right it's called
equation 1 all right
I have already used it but I need to use
it again in a different form in order to
overcome this X 1 so I'm gonna square
both sides ok so that's fine but the
reason why this is useful is because the
X Y is going to appear in the expansion
there's okay so this is great because
now I can take advantage of this in this
line right by the way just as a side
note when you've got simultaneous
equations flying around be sensible in
the name that you need in the way that
you name them ok so even though this is
like a third equation I'm gonna use a
blocker to call it equation three I'm
gonna call it equation 1a the reason why
is so that I make sure I don't you know
suburb an equation back into itself and
then you get like zero equals zero and
you're like oh great that's true what do
I do anything right so now I know I'm
gonna take this and I'm gonna bring it
down into here right so I'm going to
substitute in equation one a what's
gonna happen down here this 19 is gonna
become equal to
think about it I've got my x squared my
y squared there right so what's the
difference between these it should
become that negative XY which is always
there plus what what's gonna happen so
I'm taking these out right I'm
substituting these for these so that's
actually give me 1 minus 2xy you see
that maybe put in another line just in
case right see that do you see that so
there's my x squared plus y squared
right there now you might think oh I've
gone backwards because I've gotten rid
of what I wanted right but what I'm
doing is I'm eliminating this out of the
equation because this I can work with
have a look at it you get an 18 over
there because the 1 goes across and you
get a minus 3xy
uh-huh now I've isolated it so now I can
take that back into this line let me
just simplify a little more make you see
this
yep so now if I bring this back 19 is
equal to x squared minus negative 6 plus
y squared yeah so x squared Y squared if
I take away the 6 from both sides
there's my heart side that was 12
[Music]